Is being able to drive a car essential to becoming a psychologist, or is it just another hidden barrier? In this episode, we are unpacking a topic that's been frustrating and excluding many aspiring psychologists. Whether it's disability, cost of lessons, or the lasting impact of the pandemic, we are talking about the real life consequences of driving being perhaps an unofficial requirement for progressing in psychology careers. Hope you find it really useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist, and I speak to you as a psychologist who has
会开车对于成为一名心理学家是必不可少的，还是仅仅又是一个隐藏的门槛？在本集中，我们将探讨一个让许多有志成为心理学家的人感到沮丧和被排挤的话题。无论是残疾、学车费用，还是疫情的持久影响，我们都在讨论将开车作为心理学职业进阶的非官方要求的现实后果。希望你会觉得这非常有用。嗨，欢迎收听《有志心理学家播客》。我是玛丽安博士，一名合格的临床心理学家，我以一个
a driving licence and her own car. That is something I have had since I was an aspiring psychologist. I passed my driving test when I was age 19 in the summer of my first year undergraduate. It definitely had not come that easy to me and it was something that I spent a lot of money, a lot of time and three driving tests to perfect.
拥有驾照和自己汽车的心理学家的身份跟你交流。自从我立志成为一名心理学家以来，我就一直拥有它。我在19岁那年，也就是我本科第一年暑假的时候通过了驾考。这对我来说绝对不是一件容易的事，我为此花了很多钱、很多时间，考了三次才完美通过。
Today's podcast episode has come about as a result of me engaging with stuff on LinkedIn. I will tell you more about how this has unfolded as me and my guest Jake talk today but it's probably worth me saying if you have a suggestion for an episode for the podcast please do get in contact with me, pitch it to me or engage with me on socials and I might well suggest an episode to you too. Let's dive into our interview with Jake and I will see you on the other side. Just want to welcome our guest along today, Jake.
今天的播客节目源于我在领英上与内容的互动。我和今天的嘉宾杰克在交谈时，会向你们透露更多这背后的故事，但我也想说的是，如果你对播客的某一集有什么建议，请务必联系我，向我提出你的想法，或者在社交媒体上与我互动，我也很可能会向你建议一期节目。让我们直接进入对杰克的采访，我们在节目后半部分见。只想欢迎今天的嘉宾杰克来到节目中。
Hi Jake. Hi. How are you? I'm really well. Thank you for asking. I hope you are okay too. Thank you for reaching out to me to kind of discuss but to hold me accountable actually because I am quite opinionated about a number of different things and yeah sometimes I need to check my privilege
嗨，杰克。嗨。你好吗？我很好，谢谢你的关心。希望你也一切都好。谢谢你主动联系我来探讨这个话题，其实也是为了监督我，因为我对很多不同的事情都有相当强烈的看法，是的，有时我需要审视自己的特权，
and so I think this is a really helpful episode that's kind of come off the back of our private DMs and I never meant to offend you, I never meant to offend anybody else, but I still believe there are real advantages to being able to drive, not just in psychology, but generally. Absolutely, I do appreciate that's a kind of privileged position and that that does mean that it takes a lot of different factors to bring to fruition. So does it feel okay for you to give us a little bit of context about why what I'd said on this LinkedIn post had kind of irked you? On the LinkedIn post, it kind of irked me
所以我觉得这是一期非常有意义的节目，它源于我们之间的私信交流。我从来没有打算冒犯你，也从没打算冒犯任何人，但我依然相信，能够开车确实有很大的优势，不仅仅是在心理学领域，在生活中也是如此。当然，我很感激这是一个带有特权的地位，这意味着需要很多不同的因素才能实现。所以，你觉得分享一下背景故事可以吗？就是我在这条领英动态里说的话究竟是怎么惹恼你的？在领英的那条动态里，它让我感到有点恼火，
because what I see is a very traditional view from the older generation. I don't wanna put it as as older because you're not old. But you know what I mean. Waving a bit of privilege aside of how you raise working class, middle class, upper class. Driving wasn't really a barrier back then because like the post said, you just work at boots and you earn money and you can get a car at 17. Unfortunately, that's just not the case at the moment. You can do it if you've got nothing else to pay for or think about and you can do it if you want to put most your income in that. But the amount of people that I do know that have cars and driving
因为我看到的是老一辈人非常传统的观点。我不想把它归结为老一辈人，因为你并不老。但你知道我的意思。把关于你是工人阶级、中产阶级还是上流阶级的特权抛在一边不谈。那时候开车其实并不是什么门槛，因为就像那篇动态所说的那样，你在Boots（博姿）打工就能赚钱，17岁就能买得起车。不幸的是，目前的情况根本不是这样。如果你没有其他需要支付或考虑的开销，你就能做到；如果你愿意把大部分收入都投入到这上面，你也能做到。但是，据我所知，许多拥有汽车并驾驶
cars, it takes up a good portion of their income and they don't have to worry about entering the psychology sector itself. Like for me to afford a car I'd have to think about I need to get an un-psychology related job so I can have the pay of an assistant psychologist for now to be able to afford a car but I can't. So yeah it's more of a generational situation rather than what I think is traditional situation rather than what I think is a classist perspective, because you can talk to working class parents or whoever and they'll have the same view as like, why don't you just work harder or hard enough and you'll get it because it's so fantastic, it's a great opportunity and I feel like that's a lot of what happens with this generation is if we're not doing something, it's seen as lazy. Laziness is a very typical way, but I don't think it's quite laziness.
汽车的人，这占据了他们收入很大的一部分，而他们甚至不必担心如何进入心理学行业本身。比如，为了买得起车，我得考虑去找一份与心理学无关的工作，这样我现在才能拿到助理心理学家的薪水来买车，但我做不到。所以，是的，这更多的是一种时代现状，而不是我认为的阶级视角，因为你可以跟工人阶级父母或任何人交谈，他们也会有同样的看法，比如“你为什么不更努力地工作，或者足够努力，你就能得到了，因为这太棒了，这是一个绝佳的机会”。我觉得这一代人身上发生了很多这样的情况：如果我们不做某事，就会被视为懒惰。懒惰是一种非常典型的标签，但我认为这并不完全是懒惰。
It's a lack of motivation or understanding of the benefits, which it's not. It's capability. We're unable to do it because there's no opportunity and capability unless you're very privileged to or in a previous generation. Yeah, I hear you. And I think the mention to boots that you made was that I'd said, actually, I did pay for my own lessons. But like you said, I was living at my parents house at the time I was doing my A levels. I didn't need to pay rent, for example.
这是缺乏动力或对益处的理解，其实并不是这样。这是能力问题。由于没有机会和能力，我们无法做到这一点，除非你非常特权，或者处于前一个时代。是的，我听到你的心声了。你刚才提到Boots时，其实是因为我说过，我的学车费确实是我自己付的。但正如你所说，我考A-level时和父母住在一起。例如，我不需要付房租，
I didn't need to buy my own food. I did latterly. They did charge me rent once I came back after uni. But I appreciate that that is a privileged position, that not everyone is in that position. And some households actually, when their 16-year-old goes out to work, even when they're in full-time education, they need some of that money to support the household finances. And I do appreciate that most of my money went on HMV and Pizza Hut, driving
我不需要买自己的食物。后来我才开始付。当我大学毕业回家后，他们确实向我收取房租了。但我很感激这是一个特权地位，并不是每个人都处于这种地位。事实上，在某些家庭中，当他们16岁的孩子出去工作时，即使是在接受全日制教育，他们也需要一部分钱来补贴家用。我很感激，我大部分的钱都花在了HMV、必胜客、学车
lessons, and kind of getting covert pints from the pub, you know, because I was, I mean, I'm a June baby. So I'm a, I'm a, I'm a summer baby late, late turning 18. But yeah, that is a different position. So really, I had to ring fence my driving lessons. And the rest was, was for me to buy what we those times called going out trousers and going out tops, like, which is like a whole world away, because I am actually a huge amount older than you. I'm 43 Jake. And so this is a very different time that I was raised in. And I think that's important that we recognize that. Whereas yeah, if someone's having to contribute, that of course then does diminish their ability
以及去酒吧偷偷喝几品脱上，你知道的，因为我是……我的意思是，我是6月出生的。所以我是夏天出生的，快要满18岁了。但是，是的，那是不同的处境。所以实际上，我不得不把学车费圈定好，剩下的钱则用来买我们当时称之为“出游裤”和“出游上衣”的东西，这感觉像是一个完全不同的世界，因为我其实比你大很多。杰克，我43岁了。所以这是我成长于一个非常不同的时代。我认为我们认识到这一点很重要。相比之下，如果有人必须补贴家用，这当然会削弱他们的能力
to be able to pay. It took me a long time to drive Jake. so I had my first lesson on my 17th birthday which was June the 19th and it took me until I was 19, summer of 19, so it took me two years to pass and three attempts I passed on my third attempt and yeah I've spent a lot of money on driving but I do appreciate that I didn't have other overheads at that time. Yeah I think it's a difficult one as well because even you throughout your career and even just in driving lessons you had to work really hard to get that and manage your finances to be able to. Like overhead costs are not like you still had to work hard and it feels like it's the same climate now as it was then
来支付费用。杰克，我学开车花了很长时间。所以我的第一堂课是在我17岁生日那天，也就是6月19日，我直到19岁，即19岁的夏天才考过，所以我花了两年时间才通过，考了三次，我在第三次尝试时通过了。是的，我在开车上花了很多钱，但我确实很感激当时我没有其他的日常开销。是的，我觉得这也是一个棘手的问题，因为即使你在整个职业生涯中，甚至在学车的时候，你也必须非常努力地工作才能做到这一点，并管理好你的财务。就像日常开销一样，你仍然必须努力工作，而且感觉现在的气候和当时一样
probably to that generation but it's not and it feels like it's the same climate now as it was then probably to that generation. But it's not and it's rapidly changed in the last five years since COVID of what should be a minimum lifestyle or not. So for me, I'm lucky and fortunate enough I don't have to pay any rent. I know that's a privilege I have and I know it's something that gives me a greater chance than other people that will. I don't know, tomorrow I might have to because as much as financially I'm okay at home, I don't know the family situation at any point so I've got to think about that. But yeah, I recognise the privilege that I do have, especially like transitioning from, I say, a higher working
对那一代人来说可能如此，但事实并非如此，在过去五年新冠疫情之后的这段时间里，人们对什么是最低限度的生活方式的看法发生了迅猛的变化。所以对我来说，我很幸运也很庆幸自己不需要付任何房租。我知道这是我拥有的特权，我也知道这给了我比其他人更大的机会。我不知道，明天我可能就得付了，因为尽管我在家里经济上还可以，但我无法在任何时候都了解家庭状况，所以我必须考虑这一点。但是，是的，我承认我确实拥有的特权，尤其是从一个高阶层的工人
class background to a lower middle class in the time I've gone to uni and come back. But these barriers are here and affecting me and I feel like I'm the minimum of what could just about get by in a clinical psychologist career path these days. I can't even imagine how horrible seeing the driving license requirement on top of everything would be for someone else that has to pay rent or can't afford to volunteer twice a week, you know. It's all a different perspective and it's cost of living that's driving this unfortunately. Yeah my first kind of relevant experience role paid me 13,000 pounds a year. Obviously is not a big amount of money and yeah
阶级背景过渡到在我去上大学并回来这段时间里的低中产阶级。但这些门槛就在这里，并且正在影响着我，我觉得我处于如今在临床心理学家职业道路上勉强能混过去的最低标准。我甚至无法想象，对于一个还得付房租或者根本负担不起每周做两次志愿者的人来说，看到除了所有这些之外还要有驾照要求会有多糟糕，你知道的。这完全是不同的视角，不幸的是，正是生活成本在推动着这一切。是的，我第一份相关经验的工作年薪是13,000英镑。显然这不是一大笔钱，是的
that's basically what my salary was until I got on training. It kind of all my band four roles were paying around that but like you said I didn't have any other expenses to find. I think my first job where I actually needed to drive was when I was a home carer. I think that paid me £5.50 an hour. I loved that work and I actually learned so much about dignity, about respect, about forming lasting kind of relationships that allow me to do my job in a way that really honors the person receiving that care. And I would not have been able to do that job, which I see as a gateway job to then my relevant experience roles. Had I not had
这基本上就是我入行前的薪水。我所有的Band 4岗位薪资差不多都是这个水平，但就像你说的，我没有任何其他要应付的开销。我想我第一份真正需要开车的工作是做家庭护理员。我想那时我的时薪是5.50英镑。我非常热爱那份工作，实际上我也从中学到了很多关于尊严、尊重以及建立持久关系的知识，这使我能够以真正尊重接受护理者的方式来完成我的工作。如果我没有
my driving license, my children still find it hilarious that mommy was a home carer because they're like, Oh, you wet people's bums. Yeah, I did. And I'm proud to have done it. Like, I loved it. And I would, if I needed to, I'd go and do it again, because I learned so much. And it's, it was such a lovely way of having relationships with people. Because I wasn't just doing it for the money. Because I think often a lot of the roles that we do do,
驾照，我是不可能完成那份工作的，而我认为那是通往我后来相关经验岗位的大门。我的孩子们仍然觉得“妈妈曾是一名家庭护理员”这事特别搞笑，因为他们会说：“哦，你帮别人擦过屁股。”是的，我做过。而且我为自己曾做过而感到自豪。我太喜欢它了。如果需要的话，我会再去干一次，因为我学到了太多。而且，这是一种与人建立联系的非常可爱的方式。因为我不仅仅是为了钱而做这件事。因为我觉得通常我们所做的许多工作，
you're not driven by money. If you're driven by solely money, you go off and do something in a corporate industry, not in kind of mental health. So yeah, like it's, I guess for me, there are benefits to being able to drive. So when I've been in community settings, even when I've been an assistant, when I was working as a rehab assistant in Milton Keynes, I was able to get out to the disadvantaged communities where I was working. You know, if I'd had to wait for kind of buses, I might have seen two clients in a day. Like, there are advantages. And at that point, actually, Milton Keynes Council used to pay me as an essential car user. So I would get an amount of money per month to keep my car on the road and to pay towards my insurance. And also, I would then get my mileage paid as well. So that,
你并不是由金钱驱动的。如果你完全是为了金钱驱动，你就会去从事企业行业，而不是心理健康领域。所以，是的，我想对我来说，能够开车是有好处的。因此，当我身处社区环境时，甚至自我当助理时，当我在米尔顿凯恩斯担任康复助理时，我能够前往我工作的弱势社区。你知道的，如果我不得不等待公交车之类的，我一天可能只能见到两个客户。是的，这样做是有优势的。而且当时，米尔顿凯恩斯市议会过去还将我视为必需汽车使用者（essential car user）向我支付补贴。所以我每个月会得到一笔钱，用来维持我的车在路上行驶并支付一部分保险费。同时，我还可以获得里程补贴。所以，
you know, I think other places where they have essential car users probably do still give essential car user allowances. But I appreciate even having being able to have that car users probably do still give essential car user allowances. But I appreciate even having being able to have that car to begin with. And my cars were not shiny. They were not fancy. Even now I drive a car that is a 62 plate. So I'm not driven by shiny, really super modern cars. My first car was a Citroen AX, an e-reg Citroen AX. It was tiny, it was like a little box. I shared it with my brother. But again, like you said, if your family don't already have a car,
你知道的，我认为其他地方对于必需汽车使用者可能仍然会发放相应的补贴。但我很感激，甚至能拥有一辆车本身就是一种幸运。我的车可不光鲜亮丽，也不高级。直到现在我开的车都还是62车牌的。所以我并不是为了追求光鲜、超级现代的汽车。我的第一辆车是雪铁龙AX，一辆E登记牌照的雪铁龙AX。它很小，就像个小盒子。我和我哥哥共用它。但是，再次强调，就像你说的，如果你的家里本来就没有车，
or if there isn't a sibling that's already got a car you can share, getting that first car that cost £900 at the time is a barrier. But then that said my mum recently sold her car and it was still in working condition, it was still really good. It was probably similar age to mine. She sold that for 700 pounds and that would have made an ideal first car. So kind of comparatively, and that was a way nicer car than my first car was, comparatively there are still options for first cars which are more affordable. My children watch a lot of YouTube. And they're like, well, I'd like my first car to be a Bugatti. And I'm like, yeah, that's, that's not
或者没有一个你可以共用的车兄弟姐妹，要买下当时价值900英镑的第一辆车就是一个门槛。不过话说回来，我妈妈最近卖掉了她的车，它仍然处于可运行状态，真的非常好。它可能和我的车年龄差不多。她以700英镑的价格卖掉了它，那本会是一辆理想的第一辆车。所以相比之下——而且那辆车比我的第一辆车好看得多——相比之下，仍然有更实惠的第一辆车可供选择。我的孩子们看了很多油管视频。他们会说：“嗯，我希望我的第一辆车是布加迪。”而我说：“是的，那可真是一点都不
really that realistic. You know, so I guess it's thinking about what I staying within our means, it's really tricky. You know, I don't have a nicer car because, you know, I don't want to be spending 60, 70 grand or paying 500 pounds a month every month towards a car. Does that make sense? I like to kind of own what I have and for the moment, this is the best I can do and it's still reliable. I think there's a lot to be said for having a car that is reliable, and keeping with that
现实啊。”所以，我想这是在考虑量入为出，这真的很棘手。你知道的，我没有更好的车，因为我不想每个月花六、七万，或者每个月花500英镑来供车。这说得通吗？我喜欢拥有属于自己的东西，目前这就是我能做到的最好状态，而且它依然很可靠。我认为拥有一辆可靠的车并一直开着它，
rather than buying something that you don't know the history of. But yeah, there are there are benefits to being able to drive and being able to get yourself to these work environments. I grew up in a rural location. If I'd only been able to get where I could walk, my options for progressing in psychology would have been that much more reduced. Yeah, going to the first thing you said is you're going into this career not for the money. I get paid weekly on a Friday and I woke up and saw this morning I got paid and it's like,
而不是去买一辆你对它的历史一无所知的东西，这非常重要。但是，是的，开车以及能够自己去这些工作环境确实有好处。我在农村地区长大。如果我只能去那些我能步行到达的地方，我在心理学领域晋升的选择就会大大减少。是的，回到你刚才说的第一点，你进入这个行业不是为了钱。我每周五发工资，今天早上醒来看到我收到工资时，心想：
oh I've got paid for that, you know? It's a weird feeling because when you're working you're not thinking by looking at the clock and what am I getting paid this hour? Because that's how I was thinking when I was working as a sales assistant. I was like, okay another hour I get whatever the wage is. When I'm there working in the school, I'm just like, okay, I've just done the day, you know, and you're thinking about what you're getting out of it, what you're doing for them. It's a completely different experience. About the car stuff, which is obviously the most important part of this, I think the hardest part which is obviously the most important part of this. I think the hardest part to understand is the difference between the generations
“哦，我拿到这笔钱了，”你知道吗？这是一种奇怪的感觉，因为当你工作时，你不会一边看着时钟一边想我这个小时能赚多少钱？因为我以前在做销售助理时就是这么想的。我会想：“好吧，又过了一个小时，不管时薪是多少我都能拿到。”而当我在学校工作时，我只会觉得：“好吧，我刚度过了这一天，”你知道的，你会思考你从中得到了什么，你为他们做了什么。这是一种完全不同的体验。关于汽车的事，这显然是其中最重要的一部分，我认为最难的部分——这显然是其中最重要的一部分。我认为最难理解的是代际差异，
is the fact of the prices adjusted to inflation and the cost of living climate at the moment. Because although you went for a car that's not flashy and just got the job done, there's no incentive in me that wants a flashy car, you know, and there's nothing in me that goes well I want a Bugatti, I want an Audi, I want a Mercedes. I just want a car to be able to drive, to be able to work or get about and have a bit of freedom. And a lot of what's going on is we don't have that freedom because what car was £900 now is worth more than that
即通胀调整后的价格以及当下的生活成本压力。因为尽管你选择了一辆并不张扬、只是能满足代步需要的车，但我内心并没有任何想拥有一辆张扬的车的心思，你知道的，我心里从来没有想过什么“我想要一辆布加迪，我想要一辆奥迪，我想要一辆梅赛德斯”。我只想要一辆能开的车，能够去工作、四处走走并获得一点自由。很多正在发生的事情是，我们没有这种自由，因为以前值900英镑的车现在价值更高了，
unless it breaks down tomorrow the day after you buy it because the prices of the stuff inside the car itself is worth more than that and it's not just the car price it's the insurance it's the lessons and the tests, you know. Have you priced up insurance? How much is insurance for a young driver at the moment? So I've looked up the statistics on this because this is a thing that I do. I know it's so much money that I can't afford
除非它在你买下它的第二天或后天就抛锚，因为汽车内部零部件的价格本身就比这更高。而且不仅仅是车价，还有保险、学车和考试，你知道的。你算过保险价格吗？现在年轻司机的保险费是多少？所以我查过这方面的统计数据，因为这就是我会做的事。我知道这需要很多钱，我根本负担不起，
and I would love to drive and I've always liked cars as a kid, but I don't want to look at it because it's depressing I just hear my friends talk about it I'm like yeah that's I've got no chance you know um but the statistics say since covid it's gone up 84% the price of insurance lessons after covid add up to two thousand pounds if you have 45 of them, which is what the website said the average was. I don't want to look into it more because it frightens me and it makes me a little bit unsure about my future. And the total cost of the first year of driving of 17 to 21 year olds is £7,600 a year compared to £1,285 which was in 1985. And this is the hardest part to comprehend.
我其实很想开车，从小就喜欢车，但我不想去查，因为这太让人沮丧了，我只能听朋友们谈论它，然后心想：“好吧，我一点机会都没有了，”但是统计数据显示，自疫情以来，保险价格上涨了84%；如果上45节课的话（网站上说这是平均课时），疫情后的学车费用总共高达2000英镑。我不想再深入了解下去了，因为这让我感到害怕，也让我对自己的未来感到有点不确定。17到21岁年轻人第一年的总开车成本每年为7,600英镑，而在1985年这一数字是1,285英镑。这是最难理解的部分。
We think of £1,285 as that's a comparison but adjusted to inflation that's £3,234. Even though adjusted to inflation it's worth more money, that's still 135% increase in price of the first year of a car. And that's aside from the other cost of living that's going on. Everything's more expensive to get food to go out. I personally can't afford to go out very often at all. It'd have to be once every two weekends and that's not going out drinking.
我们认为1,285英镑只是一个对比，但根据通货膨胀调整后，那是3,234英镑。即便按照通胀调整后它代表更多的金钱，这仍然意味着第一年的用车成本上涨了135%。而这还抛开了正在发生的其他生活成本不谈。买食物、外出等一切东西都变得更贵了。我个人根本负担不起经常出门的开销。那必须是每两周才能出去一次，而且那还不是出去喝酒，
I can't do that for my health. That's going out for a meal. That's the difference in lifestyles. I hadn't considered insurance and actually, yes, privileged me. My dad paid my insurance. So bought us the car to share and paid for the insurance. And I do appreciate that is
为了我的健康我不能那样做。那是出去吃顿饭。这就是生活方式的差异。我以前没有考虑到保险的问题，说实话，是的，我很有特权。我爸爸帮我付了保险。所以他给我们买了一辆车共用，并且支付了保险费。我很感激这一点，
that is not everyone's reality. What I would say is my insurance has always been about £400 like it still is now and it was then at that time when I first had to take it on myself that was like how much you know that's a huge amount of money. But it's roughly stayed the same. I don't know why. I don't know why, but it always has. Yeah, it is a lot of money. It's, you know, I guess, similar to the kind of rental argument, like, and the house deposit argument. It's a big chunk of money to be able to find as a deposit even. Even for renting you've got to be able to pay sometimes a couple of months upfront as your deposit. Like
并不是每个人的现实情况都如此。我想说的是，我的保险费一直都在400英镑左右，现在还是这样，当时我第一次必须自己承担保险时也是这个数，当时就觉得这是一大笔钱，你知道的，这是一笔巨额资金。但它大致保持不变。我不知道为什么。我不知道为什么，但它一直如此。是的，这确实是一大笔钱。这，你知道的，我想，类似于租房论点，还有首付论点。甚至作为首付，这也是一笔需要筹集的大笔资金。即使是租房，你有时也必须能够预付几个月的房租作为押金。比如
how do you begin to be able to kind of accumulate that sort of reserve? Especially if you're for health reasons only able to work part-time. Yeah I'm literally baffled. I don't know myself what the answer is. I just work as hard as I can, do everything I can do with my time and see where I end up, you know. You're not the average applicant because when we were speaking just before we hit record,
你怎么能开始积累那种储备金呢？特别是如果你由于健康原因只能做兼职工作的话。是的，我简直百思不得其解。我连自己都不知道答案是什么。我只是尽可能努力地工作，用我的时间尽我所能去做所有的事情，然后看最终能走到哪一步，你知道的。你可不是一般的申请者，因为在我们按下录音键之前刚交谈时，
you shared with me that you ended up with a first-class degree, which really began to make you think, oh, maybe this could be my career. Clearly I've got a passion and an aptitude for that. And now you, yeah, it feels like a barrier to be able to get these jobs and progress on to becoming a trainee because many courses do have an essential requirement that you take your driving licence with you to the course. And in order to even be seen for interview, you have to submit your driving license with you to the course and in order to even be seen for
你跟我分享说你最终以一等学位毕业，这真的开始让你思考：“哦，也许这可以成为我的职业。”显然，我对这方面有着热情和天赋。现在你，是的，感觉获得这些工作并晋升为见习生是一个门槛，因为许多课程都有一个基本要求，即你必须带着驾照去上课。为了甚至获得面试机会，你必须随课程提交驾照。为了甚至获得
interview you have to submit your driving license and some people have been turned away from doctorate interviews because they either forgot their license, their license was invalid or they didn't have a license. This changes lives. Yeah there's a lot of context to go through here even where I work now there's still pokes every to go through here, even where I work now. There's still pokes every so often of have you got your driving licence? Why don't you drive here? It's so difficult to get here. But at the end of the day, I don't need to. I'm the first person there every single day. I've never been delayed because I take the earlier bus.
面试机会，你必须提交驾照，有些人甚至因为忘记带驾照、驾照失效或没有驾照而被博士面试拒之门外。这会改变人生。是的，这里有很多背景需要梳理，甚至在我现在工作的地方，也时不时会有人追问：“你有驾照吗？你为什么不开车来这里？来这里太难了。”但归根结底，我不需要。我每天都是第一个到的人。我从来没有迟到过，因为我坐的是较早的一班车。
And I've still had that judged against me, that I don't have a license, therefore reliability or whatever if it rubs off on motivation, which it does a lot on younger people, then it rubs off as a lack of motivation, but I know that's the furthest from the truth. So before I went to university, I've had no idea what to expect from it
然而这仍然被用来对我进行评判，认为我没有驾照，因此可靠性或别的什么如果折射到积极性上——对年轻人来说确实如此——那么就会被反映为缺乏积极性，但我知道这与事实相去甚远。所以在上大学之前，我对它一无所知，
because that's just not my background. My parents didn't go to university. My mum did when she was 40 to do a teaching degree, which is completely different. But we had no understanding of what to do. I have a twin sister who went to the University of Nottingham. I went to Nottingham Trent. We just, I just went there because I liked the city. I didn't know it was BPS accredited, so I was like, yeah, OK, I'll do this.
因为那根本不是我的背景。我的父母都没有上过大学。我妈妈是在40岁时去攻读教育学位的，那是完全不同的情况。但我们根本不知道该怎么做。我有一个双胞胎姐姐，她去了诺丁汉大学。我去了诺丁汉特伦特大学。我们去那里只是因为我喜欢这座城市。我当时并不知道它是经BPS认证的，所以我当时就想：“好吧，行吧，我就学这个。”
And I've always had a very big passion for psychology, and that's what I focused on my whole life. And I was like, if I do this, I'm going to get a job at it after. That wasn't the straightforward case. I went months unemployed, you know, which is really depressing to go through, especially when I've like had so many personal battles to go through, which are different to others. I've had multiple surgeries during the first year of my university life, which was combined with COVID as well. So
我一直对心理学有着极大的热情，这也是我一生都在专注的领域。当时我想，如果我学这个，我毕业后就能找到相关的工作。事情并没有那么顺利。我失业了好几个月，你知道的，经历这些真的非常令人沮丧，尤其是当我经历过许多与他人不同的个人斗争时。在大学生活的头一年里，我经历过多次手术，这又与新冠疫情交织在一起，所以
I wasn't even in the accommodation for more than let's say, two, three months when that was supposed to be a massive experience. And the quality of education was very poor because it was all virtual and I had to learn what I missed in first year and second and third year. It felt like. So I got through first year with a 2-1. Second year everything started opening up again in COVID but it's still online learning. I missed a lot of the real... I get more out of being somewhere than learning it virtually, which I think most people do. And I still had holes from the first year. made me very vulnerable to being ill all the time when everything got opened up again. And my mental health completely declined and deteriorated, which just got on top of everything. I had symptom flare ups and other health conditions. It was really, really, really a hard and low
当本应是一段重大人生经历的时候，我在宿舍里待的时间甚至都不到两三个月。而且教育质量非常糟糕，因为全都是线上的，我不得不补回我在第一年、第二年和第三年错过的东西。感觉就是这样。所以我以2:1的成绩度过了第一年。第二年，疫情期间一切开始重新放开，但仍然是线上授课。我错过了许多真实的……与虚拟学习相比，我从实地学习中获得的收益更多，我想大多数人也是如此。我第一年留下的知识漏洞，让我每当一切重新放开时，都变得非常容易生病。我的心理健康彻底崩溃和恶化，各种事情压得我喘不过气来。我的症状频繁发作，并伴有其他健康状况，那真的是一段非常、非常、非常艰难和低谷的
moment. I think my health conditions aside, I think a lot of people went through that in first and second year and the same start to uni in 2020 because of the experience. And then in third year, between second and third year I worked as a research assistant at the uni, despite not doing as well as I wanted to and having to have extensions because of my illnesses in second year. I worked as a research assistant, which completely changed everything because I was actually physically there at the uni.
时期。抛开我的健康状况不谈，我认为由于当时的经历，许多人在2020年大一和大一时都经历了这一切。然后在大三，在大二和大三之间，我在大学里担任研究助理，尽管我的表现没有达到预期，并且因为第二年的疾病不得不申请延期。我担任了研究助理，这彻底改变了一切，因为我实际上身体力行地在大学里。
I felt part of it. And it really increased my motivation again and brought back my love for what I was doing. Even though it was there, it wasn't because I didn't feel part of anything. So third year, I started really well as well, doing well on my assignments, really enthusiastic, then all of a sudden I needed a major surgery for my knee because I was unable to walk around at all at that point. That then led me to think, oh I was only going to take like a
我感到了归属感。这再次极大地提升了我的动力，找回了我对自己所做事情的热爱。尽管它一直都在，但之前我没有那种感觉，因为我没有融入其中。所以在第三年，我的开局也非常好，作业做得不错，非常热情，然后突然之间，我的膝盖需要做一次大手术，因为当时我根本无法四处走动。这随后让我心想：“哦，我本来以为只需要花一两周
month or two to recover, I just have to catch up like I have all my life, which didn't happen. The exhaustion from it because of the intensity of the surgery was incredible that I had to have my year extended into the following year and virtually self-learn everything myself again, like first and second year. That was really mentally draining and exhausting, but yeah, I still got through and I got a first. So I was like, yes, all this stress and issues are relieved from my life. I'm going to have a job. I'm not going to be financially stressed. I'm going to be able to bring my experiences to help as for other people. Experiences that span far beyond just the university experiences. I don't want to downplay them at all because
或一个月的时间恢复，我只要像一辈子那样努力赶上进度就行了，”然而并没有。手术强度带来的精疲力竭是难以置信的，以至于我的学业不得不延期到第二年，并且像大一和大二一样，不得不再次几乎靠自学完成所有内容。这在精神上真的非常折磨人、精疲力竭，但是的，我还是挺过来了，并且拿到了一个一等学位。所以我当时想：“太好了，我生活中的所有压力和问题都得到了缓解。我会找到工作的。我不会再有经济压力了。我将能够运用我的经验来帮助其他人。”这些经验远远超出了大学经历的范畴。我绝对不想淡化它们的意义，因为
obviously I'm not getting into them but they're much more intense than that. And be able to share it with other people and I was like I put all my applications that it's been a bit of a struggle and I've done well and surely that looked really good. I got a first like what more could they ask for? It turns out what more they ask for is due to sacrifice having any money and being unemployed for months. And I love volunteering, I do it, but you're required to as well. Otherwise you're stuck.
显然我没有深入展开，但它们要激烈得多。我能够与其他人分享这些，当时我想，我在所有的申请中都写道，这一路虽然有些挣扎但我做得很好，这看起来肯定很棒。我拿到了一个一等学位，他们还能要求什么呢？事实证明，他们要求的代价是牺牲所有的钱并失业几个月。我喜欢做志愿者，我也在做，但这也是硬性要求的。否则你就会被困住。
A lot of people are stuck and they have to look at other careers, no matter how passionate they are at psychology. So now I feel in a position where I can start applying to assistant psychologist jobs. I was really most faces. I was like, yes, I'm finally there. I can do it. I've got a good chance. Now my degree will mean something because I've got the experience to back up that I can do this stuff properly. And then when I opened it, nearly every single post said you're required a driving
许多人都被困住了，不得不考虑其他职业，无论他们对心理学有多么热爱。所以现在我觉得自己处在一个可以开始申请助理心理学家工作的阶段。我当时非常兴奋，心想：“太好了，我终于走到这一步了。我能做到。我有很好的机会。现在我的学位终于有意义了，因为我有经验来证明我能把这些事情做好。”然后当我打开招聘启事时，几乎每一个职位都说你必须拥有驾照。
license. I was like, where's this come from? You know, it came completely out of the blue. I understand the purpose of it if you need to drive to people's homes, and it's in multiple locations, but some some of it, it was just put on there as a luxury. It wasn't a necessity. And that luxury, I don't think that people making a post have the understanding of how discriminatory that is to really put there to people, say in my situations or other backgrounds, where they've had to take massive pay cuts and have done everything they can, have the motivation that
我当时心想：“这又是从哪儿冒出来的？”你知道的，这完全是个突如其来的打击。我理解它的目的，如果你需要开车去人们的家里，而且地点分散在多处，但有些岗位，这仅仅是被作为一种奢侈品加上去的。它并不是必需品。而这种奢侈品，我不认为发布招聘信息的人会理解，这对处于我这种情况或其他背景下、不得不大幅削减薪水并尽了一切努力的人来说是多么具有歧视性，他们拥有对心理学的热情和动力，却无法涉足这个行业。而且我参加过其他工作的集体面试，与其他那些可以通过不仅仅取决于你拥有多少钱的东西来衡量的人一样。在面试中你是看不出这一点的。所以这看起来可能像是缺乏动力，你知道的，但拥有这种动力和干劲、并尽可能努力地工作却只是在它面前设置一道门槛，这太让人执着了。我实在想不出如何在不取消志愿者工作和目前的工作、也不得不在别处不感兴趣的工作上每周干五天的情况下，去筹集驾照或开车的费用。企业级的工作不适合我，我会抑郁的，我需要回馈他人，我需要帮助他人疗愈，这能赋予我能量，
they have the love for psychology, but they can't access it. And I've been in group interviews still for other jobs, as other people where things can be measured that aren't just how much money you have. That's not really, you can't tell that from a job interview. So it can look like a lack of motivation, you know, but it's just very obsessive to have that motivation and drive and work as possible as hard as you possibly can, and then just put a barrier in front of it. I cannot think of how to fund a driving license or driving without having to cancel my volunteering and my work now and work five days a week somewhere else in somewhere I'm not interested in and I'm motivated to work. Corporate work isn't for me, I'd be depressed, I need to give back to people, I need to help people heal and that gives myself energy and
而这一切并不存在，你知道的，所以真的需要重新思考，对驾照要求所产生的影响多一点意识。是的，我认为像这样的对话开始塑造这种叙事，使其成为一种与时俱进的叙事，而不是那种在80年代、90年代和2000年代行之有效的叙事。我们现在其实处于一个非常不同的生存阶段。你知道我可爱的侄子，他22岁了，还不会开车。正如你所说，疫情确实阻碍了这一点，但它也变得更贵了。不过因为他是在城市里长大的，他其实从来不需要这样做。他的父母都会开车，祖父母也会开车，可以接送他去各个地方，或者他直接坐优步（Uber），你知道的，也许优步的崛起意味着那些
it's just it's not there you know so there really needs to be a rethink on the just being a bit more conscious of what that driving license requirement does. Yeah and I think conversations like this begin to start shaping that narrative so that it's an updated narrative rather than one that worked in the 80s and the 90s and the 2000s. We're now in actually a very different stage of existence. You know my lovely nephew, he is 22 and he doesn't yet drive. Like you said, the pandemic really had got in the way of that, but also it is more expensive. But because he was raised in a city, he's never really needed to do that. Both of his parents drive, grandparents drive and can kind of pick him up or take him places, or he just Ubers, you know, maybe this is the rise of Uber has meant that the
你无法搭便车的事情——哪怕随着你的朋友们开始学会开车，他们也会顺便载你一程——也能解决。但我明白，随着人们刚通过驾考时，是否允许车里坐有年龄在他们上下五岁以内的人，可能也会迎来一些改变。我不知道你有没有听说过这个，为了提高道路安全性并减少道路死亡人数，这似乎是该议程的愿景。但他不会开车。我在想。他挺喜欢坐优步的。我在想，优步几乎让人们省去了自己开车这个中间环节。但如果这是你必须做的事情，如果你必须拜访客户的家，你可能可以叫一辆优步，而且这会比你自己开车去并费力找停车位还要快。而且就金钱而言，有时你可以叫一辆优步，比如
things that you can't get lifts for, you know, even as your friends begin to be able to drive, you know, they will give you lifts places as well. But I understand that there might be a change coming as well with whether when people first pass their test, whether they're allowed to have people five years either side of their age in the car. I don't know if you've heard of that, to increase safety and reduce road deaths is the kind of hope for that agenda. But he doesn't drive. I do wonder. He does like an Uber. I wonder if Uber has almost enabled people to miss out the middleman of driving themselves. But if that's something that you had to do, if you had to visit a client's home, you probably could get an Uber and it would be quicker than you getting yourself there and trying
只要五英镑，车程也就是15分钟、10分钟左右。仔细想想，它不一定非得是你自己开车不可，对吧？我想大家当然都不希望所有的见习生都赶来却没一个会开车的。但如果有那么一两个人不会开车，总会有这样的实习岗位：你只需要自己前往A点。归根结底，你再次从A点离开。你其实是在说：“好吧，我坐公交车完全没问题。我能做到。而且我实际上会到得很早，因为我会坐更早的公交车，以确保我不会迟到，因为这项工作对我很重要。”但当我是一名见习生时，我在几个不同的实习岗位工作过，那些岗位性质比较分散。我当时在考文垂大学，我的雇主基地在沃里克医院。我的实习地点，其中一半在利明顿斯帕，我知道如果你不知道这些地方，
to work out where to park. And actually in terms of money, sometimes you can get an Uber for like you know five pounds that's like 15, 10 minutes away or whatever. It doesn't necessarily need, now I think about it, to be just you driving your own car does it? And I guess what of course wouldn't want is all of the trainees turning up and none of them being able to drive. But if there were a couple that couldn't drive, then there are always placements where literally you get yourself to point A. And at the end of the day, you leave again from point A. And you're saying, actually,
它们对你来说没有任何意义。而另一半在埃文河畔斯特拉特福，我住在考文垂，所以这是一个很大的辐射范围，我可能需要在这些地方之间往返。在那种情况下，要承担得起坐优步的费用是不可能的，尤其是在高峰时段，即使当时优步已经存在了。所以杰克，如果你不会开车，你真的很难完成那个实习。但有没有其他实习岗位是只集中在一个儿童和青少年心理健康服务（CAMHS）机构的，
I'd be fine to do that because I get buses. I can do that. And I'll be there early, actually, because I'm going to get the earlier bus to make sure that I'm not late because this work really matters to me. But when I was a trainee, I worked in a couple of different placements where I had kind of split posts. So I was at Coventry University and my employing base was in Warwick Hospital. And my placement, one half of the placement was in Leamington Spa, which I appreciate if you don't know these places,
比如说？是的，确实有。那你本来是有可能被分配到那些岗位的吗？是的，可能吧。我想问题在于，由于“心理学员工可以开车而且会开车”这一点已经深深植根于系统中，我想实习岗位和工作机会自然也就变成了这样。但我想也许我们可以思考一些解决方案。拼车车队（pool car）也许是个主意，这样你就无需拥有自己的车并为其购买保险了。你仍然需要会开车。但如果有拼车车队，也就是由雇主拥有车辆，你预约使用它们，比如开着它们去客户家里，或者开去参加商务会议，然后开回来把车放回车位里。作为一种机会，这可能会更具包容性，但你仍然需要具备开车的能力。
it doesn't mean anything to you. And then the other one was in Stratford upon Avon, and I lived in Coventry, so there's like a big patch that I might have been going to and from. That would have been in affordable, especially at peak times to be getting an Uber, even if Uber's existed then. So you would really struggle to do that placement, Jake, without being able to drive. But were there other placements that were just based in one cam service,
是的，当然，那会是完美的理想世界，但对我来说，优步的事情就太棒了。你刚才简直说出了我的心声。我正好住在伦敦和萨里的交界处，所以我使用伦敦交通局（TFL）的交通系统，几乎可以去到任何地方，但比方说，很多地方坐车可能要花一个半小时，但如果你开车去看，只要25、30分钟。现在我查一下优步，那段行程大概只要20英镑。
for example? Yeah, there were. And could you have potentially been offered one of those? Yeah, there were and could you have potentially been offered one of those? Yes, possibly I guess the problem is because it is so embedded in the system that that Psychology staff can drive and will drive I guess the placements and the job opportunities have kind of that's come about But I guess maybe thinking about solutions Maybe pool cars are an idea so you wouldn't then have to own and ensure your own car. You would have to be able to drive. But if there was a pool car, which is where they're owned by the employer, and you book those out, and you take them, for example, to a client's house, or you take it to a business meeting, and then you bring it back and put it in the cage. That might be more inclusive as an opportunity, but you would still have to be able to drive.
如果这意味着我能到达那里，那我就可以去。而且这比拥有一辆车要便宜。这并不是关于省去必须自己开车的中间环节，而是字面意义上的：我负担得起这个吗？是的，我可以，我负担不起一辆车，但我偶尔负担得起20英镑。或者，如果我拿着助理心理学家的薪水，我每天都负担得起去那里，因为我是因为我想做好这份工作而去做，而不是出于我们刚才说的经济原因。是的。
Yeah, of course, that would be the perfect ideal world, but be great for me with the Uber stuff. You just took the thoughts out of my head. That's exactly what I was thinking. I live literally on the border of London and Surrey, so I use TFL and I can get nearly everywhere with it, but say a lot of things can be like an hour and a half journey, but if you look at a drive, it's 25, 30 minutes. And now I look at an Uber and it's about 20 pounds
是的，我认为对于法律上不允许开车的人是有相关规定的。例如视力部分受损或注册盲人，当然，人们不会期望他们开车，他们仍然可以成为心理学家，但据我们所知，目前还没有为那些身体健康能够开车却选择不这样做的人提供相应的规定。所以也许这就是需要展开的对话，我们不能再把所有人归为同一类了。我记得还有来自《Love It or List It》节目的克斯蒂·阿尔索普（Kirsty Allsopp），她还主持过什么节目来着？
for that journey. So if that means I can get there, then I can. And it's cheaper than owning a car. And it's not about cutting out the middle man of having to drive or not. It's of literally, can I afford this? Yes or no, I can't afford a car, but I can afford 20 pounds every so often. Or say if I was working on the wage of an assistant psychologist, I could afford it every day to be there because I'm bad because I want to do job, not because of the financial reasons like we said. Yeah.
为了那段行程。所以如果这意味着我能到那里，那我就能去。而且这比拥有一辆车便宜。这并不是关于省去自己开车的中间环节。而是真正地，我承担得起这个费用吗？是的还是不是，我买不起车，但我偶尔能承担得起20英镑。或者假设如果我是按助理心理学家的薪水工作，我每天都能付得起去那里的车费，因为我是因为我想做这份工作，而不是出于我们刚才说的财务原因。是的。
Yeah, I think there are provisions for people are legally not allowed to drive. So people with that partially sighted, for example, or registered blind, of course, they wouldn't be expected to drive and they can still become psychologists, but there aren't yet, as we're aware, or provisions for people that are physically able to drive but don't. So maybe this is the conversation that needs to be had, that we can't group everybody into the same category anymore. And I know there was Kirsty Alsop from Love It or List It, and what other stuff does she do?
是的，我认为法律规定允许不会开车的人存在。例如，部分视力受损或注册失明的人，当然，人们不会期望他们开车，他们仍然可以成为心理学家，但据我们所知，目前还没有为身体有能力开车但选择不驾车的人做出的规定。所以这也许是需要进行的对话，我们不能再把每个人都归入同一类别了。我知道有来自《Love It or List It》的克斯蒂·奥尔索普（Kirsty Alsop），她还做过什么其他节目？
Stuff with Phil. She got in trouble for suggesting that people, young people basically, should just cancel their Netflix subscriptions and not pay for gym memberships or whatever in order to be able to get themselves on the property ladder. And that was very publicly discriminated about and still is the kind of the content of memes. And I don't wanna be like the psychology equivalent
菲尔的那期节目。她因为建议人们——基本上是年轻人——应该取消Netflix订阅，不付健身房会员费或其他什么费用，以便能让自己买得起房，而惹上了麻烦。这在当时遭到了公开的批评，到现在它还是一种网络梗的内容。我不想成为那种心理学层面的
for Kirsty Allsop and I like Kirsty Allsop, but you know, this is what she'd said, she said what she said. I still think driving is a useful skill like it's and as I said on that post it's allowed me to do so many wonderful things Jake you know it's allowed me to on my kind of gap six months go off and drive in New Zealand and drive on the largest sand island in the world Fraser Island and drive on the largest sand island in the world, Fraser Island in Australia. And again, even being able to backpack is privileged, I get that. But I saved the six months to be able to do that. But even being able to drive my children to health appointments,
对应柯斯蒂·奥尔索普（Kirsty Allsop）的人物——我其实挺喜欢柯斯蒂·奥尔索普的，但你知道，这就是她说过的话，她确实说了。我依然认为开车是一项很有用的技能，正如我在那篇帖子中所说的那样，它让我做了很多美好的事情，杰克。你知道，它让我在大约六个月的间隔年里，去新西兰开车，去世界上最大沙岛——澳大利亚的弗雷泽岛开车。当然，即使能去背包旅行也是一种特权，我明白这一点。但我存了六个月的钱才得以成行。然而，哪怕只是开车带我的孩子们去健康预约，
I had two caesarean sections and I've also broken my arm. And those periods of not being able to drive, because I can usually drive, I found really, really hard. I did actually download and use Uber for the first time during that time when I broke my arm, which was a couple of years ago. Um, and yeah, I've seen, I use Ubers all the time now, whereas until, until I couldn't use my car, I didn't. So I do still use Ubers, but I use my car. You know, like the Joey Tribbiani episode on Friends when he's like, when he can't do what the Joey Tribbiani does, and then when he's allowed to, does he go back to his old ways? Yes, he does.
我经历过两次剖腹产，还骨折过手臂。在那些不能开车的日子里——因为我通常都能开车，我发现真的、真的很难熬。事实上，几年前当我手臂骨折时，我确实在那期间第一次下载并使用了优步（Uber）。嗯，是的，我发现现在我经常使用优步，而在我不能使用汽车之前，我是不用的。所以现在我确实还会用优步，但我还是以开自己的车为主。你知道，就像《老友记》里乔伊·崔比亚尼（Joey Tribbiani）的那集一样，当他不能做乔伊·崔比亚尼做的事时，而当他被允许时，他会回到老路上去吗？是的，他会的。
he does. But I like having Uber as, this should be sponsored by Uber this episode, but it's not. I like having that as an ability to be able to use as and when needed, but I do like and need be able to get my children to their swimming lessons and get myself to the gym and live independently and get my shopping. I find it all easier with a car. So I do work from home these days. But a great majority of the jobs I've had, even as a qualified clinical psychologist, in fact, my first job was working in two settings. One was about 15 miles from the other. So they both needed, that needed me to be able to drive. And then when I worked for the NHS, I worked in a peripatetic manner across four or five different sites on four days a week. So I needed to be able to drive for that as well. So yeah, I don't think there's an easy suggestion. But this is a start, this is a conversation about why can't we give people fixed workplaces, I guess, so that it makes it more accessible for those that don't drive, either because they can't or because they don't choose that for themselves.
他会的。但我喜欢把优步作为——本集应该由优步赞助，但并没有。我喜欢把它作为一种按需使用的能力，但我确实喜欢而且需要开车送孩子们去上游泳课，自己去健身房，独立生活并去买日用品。我觉得有车会让这一切变得更轻松。所以现在我在家办公。但我做过的大多数工作，甚至作为一名合格的临床心理学家时也是如此，事实上，我的第一份工作需要在两个地点工作。其中一个距离另一个大约15英里。所以这两处地方都需要我能够开车。后来在NHS（英国国家医疗服务体系）工作时，我每周有四天需要在四五个不同的地点之间奔波。所以为此我也必须得会开车。所以，是的，我不认为有什么简单的建议。但这只是个开始，这是一个关于为什么我们不能为人们提供固定工作场所的讨论，我想，这样可以让那些不会开车的人——无论是不会还是自己选择不开车——能更方便地工作。
Or give them time to be able to learn whilst they're there. A lot of it is such little training for people that haven't been given the opportunity to be trained or experience these things. And I'm also sure if I cancel my £30 gym membership, I'd be able to own a house, you know, the thing that balances my mental health, my physical health and my social life, given that I can't afford to do anything else. I'm sure I'm sure that's the answer, you know? That's why it didn't go down well. It didn't go down well. This isn't frivolous things that people are having. It is actually what makes life livable and enjoyable and copeable with. So yeah, I do agree with that. And those three pound lattes that give me a workspace in a coffee shop. I'm sure if I cancelled that out, it's just life changing. I don't know why I didn't think
或者给他们时间让他们在工作时学习。很多时候，对于那些没有机会接受培训或体验这些事情的人来说，提供的培训实在太少了。而且我也确信，如果我取消我那30英镑的健身房会员资格，我就能买得起房子了，你知道的，那个能维持我的心理健康、身体健康和社交生活的项目，鉴于我根本承担不起别的任何开销。我确信，我确信这就是答案，对吧？这就是为什么这个言论反响不好。反响很不好。人们拥有的并不是什么轻浮的东西。这实际上是让生活变得能够忍受、充满乐趣并能够应付过去的基础。所以，是的，我确实同意这一点。还有那些让我能在咖啡馆拥有一个工作空间的3英镑拿铁。我相信如果我把它戒了，生活就会发生天翻地覆的变化。我不知道我当时怎么就没想到
about myself. I think it was lattes and avocados, I think she said about at the time. Yeah, it didn't go down well. But thank you so much for contacting me. Thank you so much for holding me accountable. I am not perfect, but I am willing to admit that. And I, every day should be a school day. We should be aware of our vulnerabilities. We should be aware of when we come off like an ass,
这一点。我想她当时说的是拿铁和牛油果。是的，那次反响确实不好。但非常感谢你联系我。非常感谢你对我的监督。我并不完美，但我愿意承认这一点。而且我坚信，活到老学到老。我们应该意识到自己的脆弱性。我们应该意识到自己什么时候表现得像个混蛋，
like, you know, because I want to make sure that I'm being as inclusive in what I say and what I do. So I'm always wanting to, in terms of my intersectionality, be more aware of my blind spots, but also aware of the fact that I am 43. And I'm having a different experience. I had a different experience of my youth than you are having of yours.
就像，你知道的，因为我想确保我在言行上尽可能具有包容性。所以我总是希望在我的交叉性（intersectionality）方面，更加意识到自己的盲点，同时也意识到这样一个事实：我今年43岁了。我正在经历不同的人生。我对青春的体验跟你对青春的体验是不同的。
And maybe the two are not comparable in terms of expecting you to be able to drive? I would say it's not comparable to the youth of five years ago, which is even harder to comprehend. And I have a few more comments as well, really. I think there's a big issue with the cost of living and perspective on young people. Like the story you're saying with the guy from Thres who got the stuff taken away from him that would made him him. We haven't had the stuff given to us to make us us. So I think there's a bit of survivorship bias in
也许这两者在期望你能开车这一点上是没有可比性的？我会说，它甚至跟五年前年轻人的情况没有可比性，这就更难以理解了。实际上，我还有一些其他的评论。我认为生活成本和对年轻人的看法存在一个大问题。就像你提到的那个在Thres工作的小伙子的故事，他被拿走了那些让他成为他自己的东西。我们并没有得到那些能让我们成为我们自己的东西。所以我认为这里面存在一种幸存者偏差，
all of this. And we're trying so desperately to be able to have those things or know what these things are that we haven't had the opportunity. Absolutely. Like I think had I not been able to go out and do all of the things and really live my life in those formative years, it would have felt like I'd had my wings clipped. And so, you know, this, we thought the pandemic was going to be a few weeks or a few months. And actually, we've just had a five year anniversary, there's still COVID around now, like this is, this has a lasting impact on people. Yeah we tend to forget because it's basically a traumatic event across everyone but it's easier to forget that it didn't
所有这些都是如此。我们如此拼命地想要拥有这些东西，或者去了解这些我们没有机会经历的事情。绝对是这样。就像我认为，如果我当时没有能够出去经历所有这些事情，在那些塑造性格的年岁里真正地生活，我会觉得自己就像是被剪断了翅膀。所以，你知道的，我们曾以为大流行只会持续几周或几个月。但事实上，我们刚刚迎来了大流行五周年纪念，现在周围仍然有新冠病毒，就像这，这会对人们产生持久的影响。
happen or it wasn't so bad because everyone did. But we don't acknowledge how it affects life right now, economically or socially. It's completely changed everything. Yeah, I think, I think people are more aware of the impact it had on COVID babies. So the COVID babies are now in reception year. And there's more of a dialogue around the impact that COVID had on child rearing and child socialisation, actually. I think the impact it's had on people your age is needing more air and more conversation, and I hope that this forms part of that narrative. Yeah, and I hope it really opens up a few eyes on job posts
是的，我们往往会忘记，因为它基本上是每个人都经历过的一场创伤性事件，但更容易让人忘记它其实发生过，或者它其实没那么糟，因为大家都这么过来了。但我们没有承认它现在对经济或社会生活产生了怎样的影响。它彻底改变了一切。是的，我认为，人们对它对“疫情宝宝”的影响有了更多认识。所以“疫情宝宝”现在已经上学前班了。关于疫情对育儿和儿童社交化产生的影响，现在有了更多的讨论。我认为它对你们这个年龄段的人产生的影响需要更多的关注和讨论，我希望这能成为那种叙事的一部分。
about why they might be missing things. It's not missing because of us. It's missing because it's not there. I can't... anything aside, I can't think of how I could have worked any harder in any given moment of time when I spend my whole life working hard because I'm that passionate. If I have any gaps anywhere, I can promise you it's not working hard because I'm that passionate. If I have any gaps anywhere I can promise you it's not anything to do with how motivated or capable I am and I think that's something to acknowledge especially when there's other applicants that might have not gone through the same things that they have it. It's likely because they've had the support to be able to do that. Yeah, your aptitude and your perservation shines out of you.
是的，我希望这能真正开阔人们对招聘启事的眼光，了解他们为什么可能会错过某些东西。不是因为我们不够好而错过。而是因为根本没有这些东西。我无法……抛开一切不谈，每当我把整个生命都投入到工作中时，我无法想象自己在任何特定的时刻还能如何更加努力，因为我对工作充满热情。如果我在任何地方有所欠缺，我向你保证，这绝对不是因为不够努力，因为我对工作充满热情。如果我在任何地方有所欠缺，我向你保证，这绝对与我的积极性或能力无关，我认为这是需要承认的一点，特别是当还有其他候选人可能没有经历过同样的困境时。这很可能是因为他们得到了能够做到这一点的支持。是的，你的天赋和坚持不懈闪耀着光芒。
So I think you will get to be going to great places. You know, you're already on that journey, but it's what organizations can do to flexibly include and accommodate you that's gonna be really important. I feel like my children are always telling me that I need to say this. And so I feel like with perhaps one of my youngest guests to date, that it might be my time to say this.
所以我认为你会走向美好的未来。你知道，你已经在那个旅程中了，但组织能够做些什么来以灵活的方式包容和关照你，那才是真正重要的。我觉得我的孩子们总是在提醒我必须说这句话。所以我觉得，对于我迄今为止最年轻的嘉宾之一，也许这也是我该说这句话的时候了。
They want me to point and say, what do you think if you're watching this on YouTube? Comment below. And they say, I never point. So I'm pointing, children. OK. I would love anyone watching or listening to this to, you know, to let us know in the comments, either as a question on Spotify, or as a
他们希望我指着屏幕说：“如果你在YouTube上观看这个视频，你觉得怎么样？请在下方评论。”他们说我从来不指。所以我指了，孩子们。好的。我很乐意任何观看或收听这个节目的人，（你知道的），在评论中让我们知道，无论是在Spotify上提问，还是作为
review or a comment on social media, or if you're watching on YouTube, in the actual comments. Has this resonated with you? You know, what do you think about what Jake and I have been talking about today? Thank you so much for your time, Jake. It's been a really, really interesting and thought provoking conversation. And I hope it's OK for you too. Thank you very much. It really is. And I will say, as having a twin, and obviously that means we have the same financial background, there's that privilege there financially that I haven't had to struggle overly in terms of safety and security.
社交媒体上的评论或评价，或者如果你在YouTube上观看，就在实际的评论区里留言。这引起了你的共鸣吗？你知道，你对我和杰克今天讨论的内容有什么看法？非常感谢你抽出时间，杰克。这是一次非常非常有趣且引人深思的对话。希望对你来说也很愉快。非常感谢。确实如此。而且我要说的是，作为双胞胎，显然这意味着我们有相同的经济背景，在经济上存在那种特权，我在安全感和保障方面没有经历过过多的挣扎。
So, for example, my sister's been able to save up and she's in Australia at the moment, albeit she's not driving. She's in Australia at the moment having a great time. It's just how life is in the psychology career path that she has the opportunity to do that and work in a coffee shop for a few months before to afford it. Well what I would say is if your sister can't drive Fraser Island is amazing so make sure she makes a friend who can drive and tell her to go to Fraser Island because it's so much fun. I will do. Thank you for your time Jake. Thank you. Oh, thank you so much to our guest for today, Jake. Wishing you the very best in your career, Jake. And I think we're going to be watching this space.
所以，例如，我姐姐能够攒下钱，她现在在澳大利亚，尽管她不会开车。她现在在澳大利亚玩得很开心。心理学职业道路上的生活就是这样，她有机会做到这一点，并且在之前去咖啡馆工作几个月来承担费用。嗯，我想说的是，如果你姐姐不会开车，弗雷泽岛太棒了，所以一定要让她结交一个会开车的朋友，并告诉她一定要去弗雷泽岛，因为那里太有趣了。我会的。谢谢你抽出时间，杰克。谢谢。哦，非常感谢我们今天的嘉宾杰克。祝你在职业生涯中一切顺利，杰克。我想我们会拭目以待的。
Like I said, if you've got ideas for future podcast episodes, please do feel free to come and pitch those to me either directly from my website www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk or come and follow me on social media where I am Dr. Marianne Trent Everywhere. If you love these energized conversations that really help you to be shaped and to grow and to be developed then I think you will really really enjoy the aspiring psychologist membership. It's your chance to get up close and personal with qualified psychologists to really help your development. You can join for just 30 pounds a month with no minimum term and when you join you can gain access to the
就像我说的，如果你对未来的播客节目有任何想法，请随时来找我推销，可以直接通过我的网站 www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk，或者在社交媒体上关注我，我到处都是“Marianne Trent博士”。如果你喜欢这些充满活力、真正能帮塑造你、让你成长和发展的对话，那么我想你一定会非常非常喜欢“有志心理学家会员专区”（The Aspiring Psychologist Membership）。这是你与合格心理学家近距离接触、真正助力你发展的大好机会。你只需每月支付30英镑即可加入，没有最低期限要求，加入后你还可以访问
replay content for the last three years. It really is great we're doing brilliant things and we're getting people assistant psychologist interviews and jobs, research assistant posts and trainee interviews and places too. There's so much to celebrate please do come on board and if you decide you're going to join for a longer time period up front, six months for example or one year, year, you also get one to one time with me as well too. If you'd like to come and join the free Facebook group, you can do. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Treads. And that is the exclusive home of Marianne's motivation and mindset sessions, which happen
过去三年的回放内容。这真的很棒，我们正在做很棒的事情，我们正帮助人们通过助理心理学家面试和工作、研究助理职位以及见习生面试和名额。有太多值得庆祝的事情了，请一定要加入我们。如果你决定提前加入更长的时间，例如六个月或一年，你还将获得与我一对一交流的时间。如果你想加入免费的Facebook群组，你可以这样做。它是与玛丽安·特伦特博士一起建立的“有志心理学家社区”（The Aspiring Psychologist Community）。那是玛丽安的动力与心态专场专属阵地，时间在
each Friday morning. You can also check out my books, The Aspiring Psychologist Collective and The Clinical Psychologist Collective too. Thank you so much for being part of my world. The next episode will be along on YouTube from 10 a.m. on Saturdays and wherever you get your podcasts from 6 a.m. on Mondays. Take care.
每周五早晨。你还可以查看我的书，《有志心理学家合集》（The Aspiring Psychologist Collective）和《临床心理学家合集》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。下一期节目将于周六上午10点起在YouTube上播出，周一上午6点起在你获取播客的任何平台上播出。保重。
If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side To be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Mary Antrim There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你渴望成为一名心理学家，那就让它成为你的向导吧。有这个播客在你身边，助你迈向获得资质的道路。这就是《有志心理学家播客》，我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。